تماما في الموعد كتائب القسام هي من حدد
التوقيت وهي من ضبط كثافه الرشقات
الصاروخيه
وا تنهمر صواريخها القادمه من غزه على
عسقلان بعد انقضاء مهله منحتها لسكان
المدينه
لاخلاقها وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه افادت
بسقوط قتلى جراء هذا القصف الصاروخي
المكثف قصف تقول المقاومه الفلسطينيه انه
ردها على تهجير قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للمدنيين في القطاع واذا لم يتوقف التهجير
فستواجه عسقلان وستنتقل لتهجير مدينه اخرى
انه امتداد للطوفان الاقصى الذي يندفع
الان في شكل رشقات صاروخيه باتجاه العديد
من المدن والمستوطنات
الاسرائيليه من مدن العمق الاسرائيلي التي
طاولها قصف كتائب القسام ايضا بدفعات
صاروخيه اسدود وبئر السبع وقبلهما تل ابيب
تل ابيب التي تعرضت الاستهدافات صاروخيه
واسعه دوت صفاره الانذار في محيط مطارها
الشهير بن
جريون وكذلك الامر في جميع مستوطنات ما
يعرف بغلاف غزه بين مستوطنه كفار عزه
وشاعر هانف وكذا سديروت حيث بلغ عن
اشتباكات
مسلحه ولم يكن الاستنفار اقل في مستوطنه
افيفيم في الجليل
الاعلى الغالب على القصف الصاروخي الذي
تنفذه المقاومه انه ياتي على دفعات مكثفه
متتاليه من شان ذلك التكتيك منحها نفسا
اطول في اداره المعركه كما انه يربك
منظومه اسرائيل الدفاعيه الجويه ويحو الى
جهد اكبر لاعاده تلقيم القبه الحديديه
بالصواريخ
الاعتراضيه مهمه الاعتراض نفسها تبدو شاقه
لا سما بعد ان تعددت مصادر الاطلاق من
جنوب لبنان وتحديدا من سهل القليله تنطلق
دفعه من الصواريخ باتجاه الجليل الغربي
على الجانب الاسرائيلي من الحدود ي ي
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف المناطق التي
انطلقت منها الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان
بالقذائف
المدفعيه الاذاعه الاسرائيليه الرسميه
اثارت من جانبها احتمال تسلل مسلحين من
لبنان الى منطقه شلومي القريبه من الحدود
مع
لبنان